afternoon I'm cap good day to you I'm
down very formal
we're the slow mo guys now in the past
we've done giant balloons full of war
popping yeah never seen how big they got
with just air in the day well how big it
gets why supposedly six feet so I'm
thinking we could sit you on top of one
yeah and pop it see if you'd be hovering
in the air and when that inevitably
fails we'll stick you inside it in just
a balloon full of air what I mean that's
what they're meant for their climbing
balloon so just I wonder if you can
actually be able to stand fully upright
inside there
have you always to strike a pose I tried
blowing up with my mouth it wasn't
happening so got LeFleur now funnily
enough this is not a leaf blower that I
actually owned already we bought it
specifically for this purpose I'm glad
we went to blue on blue very easy to see
what's happening
all right I love it
put the husband's back
so because we want you actually sat on
the balloon we're now doing some
Anchorage for our handles visa hold on -
yeah tie these two strings to the trees
and hopefully just sort of balance my
way on top of the balloon leaning back
you have good core strength II could be
all about the stomach i think you know
ii ii ii ii
you know so I said that failed it got
too big so I guess climb inside and
we'll see if we can stuff it with you
outside how is it not there in the air
out why you just climbing headfirst
though most people put it over their
heads it's so painful good like to be
moistened you don't not a moister you
but you want to help you pull over your
knees so tight alright well fire up the
little e flow
thoughts
getting naked it is pulling my shorts
now that does not look appealing
my pose went straight out the window
that pose was phenomenal thank you she
actually worked exactly how I imagined I
had so much time in there
I always literally watch pusher do still
what's best
yeah maybe a great unveiling yeah if I
have to replace you and I don't lose
them ago hopefully you enjoyed that
video feel free to follow us on the
twits buy a shirt buy a poster
subscribe subscribe the most important
one of all watching all of our other
videos we've gone over a hundred these
days these days hours see you next time